so our summer fun series continues this
morning with a unique camp aimed at
future computer coders and developers
and this
one involves ninjas hector mejia live up
in centennial hills with more on that
good morning hector
hey there alex isn't that cool so
they've mixed martial arts with the art
the skill of coding and joining us this
morning
and having us this early in the morning
we have craig to explain how they have
mixed martial arts
with coding good morning teaser yeah um
so just like a martial arts studio
they're going to have belts where
they're going to progress and then
right over here we have our totem our
totem essentially is the same thing you
would see at any kind of karate studio
and we're looking at where they start
out at white belt all the way down the
bottom
and as they belt up they start moving
their
uh they start moving their names up
every belt ceremony
that is so cool so kids basically have
an incentive or something to look
forward to
yes absolutely and we make it a big deal
we try to make it a big celebration
and a big ceremony we have a script and
everything tell us about the classrooms
and just exactly how do you code
well basically what is coding coding is
a language where we tell the computers
what to do so um if we're looking at
and can i show you a project or of
course so you can't just walk up to the
computer and say
turn off no no no so you're telling the
computer what to do so
in our summer camp case we're doing
something called storytelling
where um if we start uh like here
you have a cat that has a sun here
the sun starts talking to the cat the
cat says hello
that starts becoming a story with our
regular coding we have
different we have different
levels of games that they could build
before we run out of time how can
kids say hello to these week-long
programs when do they start what are the
ages
and pricing so we essentially have seven
to 14
with also a non-reading program five to
seven
our regular program right now is 219 a
month they come in for two hours
a week and it starts out we have a
monthly discount if you sign up on the
day of your uh tour
it's uh 1 59 right now awesome and you
guys also lastly offer scholarships
yes we do we actually are full with our
scholarships right now
but we have and work with another group
called young and empowered
which actually sponsors our kids and we
sponsor ourselves three kids
awesome thank you for your time we'll be
posting all of the information
for all the parents and children on our
website and that is eight newsnow dot
com
for now reporting live hector mejia
eight news now back to you guys
hector you're so funny unfortunately we
cannot walk over and tell the computer
verbally what to do thank you so much
have fun out there
our summer fun series continues all this
week tomorrow we're going to take you
over to the lion habitat ranch
in henderson so be sure to join us for
that